Công ăn thình của họ nổi cho biết, nguyên bị này đang quyết liệm chấn trình sẽ chặt thì loại khi tiên cho công tác quan lý cho tự đồ thi,
đánh chức dệm của thề đến tình cả nhân đồ vi, trong tháng 3 năm nay thì tự cho khai sấu,
lực lượng chức năng đã sử lý phản hội bàn ninh chiến chăm xếng ở bií thạm cho tự đồ thi qua hệ thống camera,
ra phản ánh của người dân với tổ thủ tiền hơn bốn phế bà trí đồng.
Nếu đó, nhiều tự phố được chiến chân, tình chạng lẫn chiến về hàn lòng đường, tự bước được chiến chế,
ý thức của người dân có chuyện biến, tuy nhiên, đi phạm vẫn chưa được xử lý động đều.
Một số địa bàn còn tài dẫn tác lỗi nhiều lần chiến về hè, tình dòi chai phép, dừng đổ xa của đình.
Chức thực chạm này, Công ăn thình của anh nổi đã để xuất thường chức khách quyy,
xem xét chắc giận các quyy chính quyền được phương để xảy ra bí phản kéo dài.
Với các hiểm thức từ hạm mất kí đua đến xem xét công tác hảm bộ.
Trong lỗi bộ lực lượng, Công ăn thình phố cũng tăng cường chạm,
sự lý chách giận công ăn cấp cơ sở, điện hình tài phương cơ năm,
chường công ăn phương, phó chường công ăn phương của chách lĩnh vực chật tử rô thi,
và mấy bốn cánh bộ cành sách chật tử ở trực tiếp của chách các quyền phố đã bị xem xét chết giật,
với hình thức phân lại cánh bộ tháng 3 năm, mình phục trọng hais háo ước mất thông hảm phay nhìn bộ.
Gió để xảy ra nhiều vì phạm về chật tử rô thi và uống tác ra thông trên đề bàn.